[Music]
[Applause]
penguin highway premiered at the
Fantasia International Film Festival in
Canada last year and then it was
released in Japan went through a lot of
film festivals animation based ones
primarily and will soon be released in
America here in the coming weeks and
this is directed by hiroyasu Ishida and
is his first feature which follows a
young boy who's extremely smart he's in
fourth grade way ahead of everyone else
in his class he takes extensive notes of
everything that he discovers or things
that he's curious about he conducts
experiments regularly his father gives
him chores to do and most of these
chores revolve around some sort of
scientific experiment or exploration and
he's extremely excited about doing this
and one day
penguins show up in a park there's no
explanation for why the Penguins are
suddenly there and of course as a young
budding scientist he wants to explore
why this happened and in so doing he
embarks on an adventure with another
student from his class who's also
interested in science together they
study another strange find in a nearby
forest well at the same time he's
experiencing his first ever crush on a
dental assistant who's a lot older than
he is
and she might just so have a weird
connection with all these events penguin
Highway is one of the strangest films
I've seen in a long time and it's
perfectly fine with being that in fact
this film does not care about rules it
is filled with so many unexplainable
events and phenomena and it asks us to
accept what we see and roll with it
don't get me wrong this is no masaaki
yuasa film like mine game or night a
short walk on girl there's a sensible
storyline that develops throughout this
film even though I love both those
movies I just mentioned this film looks
at unexplained phenomena through the
eyes of a fourth grader and his view of
these events are different from what
most adults would expect if there were
penguins suddenly in my front yard for
instance I'd probably be freaking the
fuck out but this kid just grabs a
notebook and starts taking notes because
he's free still even though he's a lot
smarter than the other kids his age he
still looks forward to things like this
happening and he views it as an
opportunity to advance his knowledge of
the world and this film reminded me what
feels like to be a child to feel that
freedom to not put so much effort into
caring about the things happening around
me but to focus purely on the things
that inspire me and that excite me
creatively in the case of the boy in
this film it's not about creativity it's
about the knowledge it's about looking
for an answer searching for something
digging really deep to figure out why
these insane things are happening all
around him and the movie hopes that has
audience members we're not going to look
at it and go what the hell's going on
why is all this happening and wants us
to just enjoy the ride and even with his
older friend in the film the dental
assistant she is still trying to figure
out exactly what her place in the world
is because through this boy's
experiments she's learning things about
herself but also getting excited about
feeling a lot younger again and after a
while she finds herself willing to
accept the unexplainable at face value
and just go with it and see where it
leads
this film was based off of a novel
written by Tommy he kimura me his books
also inspired the night is short walk on
girl and the tatami galaxy and I'm
really happy to see one of his works so
well translated to a film because he
writes science fiction that doesn't
necessarily feel like science fiction
technically what we see in this movie is
sci-fi but it does not feel that way it
feels like a coming-of-age movie with
this sci-fi background the film looks
beautiful in particular the shot
structure it's not just a well animated
film with really wonderfully rendered
locales
I loved wherever the director chose to
put his camera to highlight his
characters journeys because I've always
been a big fan of the paranormal and
investigating it even in like crazy
stupid Netflix documentaries that aren't
real but are fun to watch whenever I see
a film that uses that as a backdrop to
tell a story that feels like it has
emotional weight that's just so
satisfying to me and everything about
this movie came together really well but
there is one storyline about it that I
thought was just a little weird because
it has a major element to the plot and
that is this crush that this fourth
grader has on the older girl they focus
on it a lot and he focuses on the
woman's body a lot and I get that that's
normal for a ten-year-old boy who's sort
of figuring things out but where most
films might take a relationship like
that and say oh you're just a cute kid
and
it's adorable that'll never happen this
film sort of hints that maybe in the
future sort of and so I don't know it
was just a little uncomfortable and I
could see some people finding that a
little odd but that's about it in
regards to issues I had with this movie
i sat down to watch the film because
eleven arts was kind enough to send me a
screener of it and I was planning on
watching maybe the first half because I
had a lot of stuff to do that day but I
found myself so invested in it I just
watched the whole thing I just
completely forgot what my plans were for
the rest of the day and I sat there and
I watched the whole thing because I was
just so invested in it it's a really
wonderful movie that has a great and
unique look at what science fiction
could be for a family-based film
although I could see this being more
like 13 and up because of a few things
that happen in the movie just from like
a more maturity level still it's it's
definitely aimed at younger audiences or
at least people who are around the main
characters age and to see a film like
this that has this sci-fi elements in it
it's just really refreshing I'm gonna
give penguin highway and a - guys thank
you so much as always for watching I'm
excited for more people to see the film
and for it to get a release in the
United States as always guys look
forward to more reviews very soon and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stubborn eyes
[Music]